prêt pour en débattre nous sommes avec
joël à melen un député européenne et
rennes lui ne victor omer udi de
combrand bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être là je précise que vous êtes tous
les deux médecins six médecins m'ont dit
à chaque fois joëlle mélin mais on
l'aurait sa vie comme je vous dis à
chaque fois merci en tout cas ludovic
toro 1 qui semble-t-il serait en train
de vacciner à l'asra dans son cabinet
merci d'être avec nous en direct alors
un mot pour commencer justement sur ce
vaccin que vous utilisez ludovic toro
des nouveaux doutes des nouvelles
préoccupations tout cas autour de ce
sérum elles viennent des états unis
aujourd'hui nous les autorités de santé
ont des doutes sur la fiabilité des
données qu'ils auraient été au sol est
ça ne veut pas dire que le vaccin n'est
pas bon mais voilà il y avait un point
de confiance en tout cas qui s'érode
entre le laboratoire astrazeneca et les
états unis
est ce que le régulateur américain a
raison de se méfier de ce vaccin sera
zeneca genre et mélangez pas qu aux
millions 11 millions d'anglais qui ont
été vaccinées à un million quatre en
france il faut qu'on arrête de mettre
des doutes sur tous les vaccins quel que
soit le vaccin parce que sinon sortira
jamais de cette pandémie
on sait très bien que le moyen de sortir
cette pandémie c'est la vaccination
alors on trouvera toujours des des cas
où il ya des effets secondaires des
choses comme ça mais c'est des cas qui
auraient eu lieu quand même c'est à dire
que ça existe des gens qui décèdent ça
existe et les allergies ou cela mais
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter mais que
haro sur les vaccins nous avons des
autorités sanitaires pour l'europe on a
là et même de l'europe pour la france il
a et même de la france voilà point final
maintenant ce que disent les autres ils
peuvent le dire comme une folle nous on
est en france pour essayer de soigner
les gens mais bien au delà des prévenir
de surf de ce vide mais dans le monde
c'est pareil donc ce qu'on arrête feront
parce que l'on a un travail après très
très compliqué sur la vaccination quand
on reçoit les gens pour les vacciner
jack ce n'est pas très facile parce
qu'elle astrazeneca avait été mis en
doute au début mais maintenant avec les
cas qui arrive un peu de chaque pays
sont tous les pays du nord c'est
compliqué je rappelle encore que l'on
est et en ile de france
aujourd'hui mais la pandémie elle
explose on est un peu de 604 300 mille
mois sur la scéne et céline département
où j'exerce il y a urgence à agir
et donc cette défiance par rapport aux
vins
en attendant c'est un tout petit peu
amènes hervé vu le joli et très peu
d'effets secondaires qu'on a pu noter on
comprend votre agacement ludovic toro ce
mets à votre place mais enfin ce n'est
pas loin les médias qui jetons cette
suspicion la floride de l'autorité et
surtout souffrent-ils de victor o
pardonnez moi mais c'est la france qui a
quand même suspendu l'astra zeneca
c'était peut-être une faute hein alors
attendez on va être clair en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est des pays nordiques et
ont tenu un moment l'allemagne l'italie
d'abord appuyer sur les boutons pour
cette une région après l'allemagne a
appuyé et la france est venu par la
suite parce qu'il faut garder une
position européenne qui à mon avis n'est
pas aussi forte que ça ils vont le voir
puisque 13 clairement certains pays
aujourd'hui
signe des contrats il s'approche du
spoutnik il faut le dire il ya l'italie
il ya l'allemagne à l'espagne voilà ce
sont des faits aujourd'hui d'accord donc
non c'est pas vous tue pas que ces
journalistes mais je digresse
ce vaccin qu'on a le plus beau c'est la
commande des plans mais de gros seins
pour notre pays et on va s'en passer
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas possible
c'est ou alors si non excusez-moi mais
en termes d'utilité collective
on va même plus parler de 2021 on va se
projeter en 2022 lancé par jour et
demain vous comprenez l'agacement de
ludovic toro alors c'est vrai que la
france a suspendu la strazeele et cas
les français étaient déjà pas vraiment
conscient il ya beaucoup de scepticisme
on le sait quant aux vaccins en france a
fait du mal à ce vaccin avec des
derniers développements avec les états
unis aujourd'hui ça n'arrange pas les
choses
évidemment pas les choses
c'est très dommage puisque nous sommes
dans une situation où malheureusement se
passe comme si nous n'avions pas
d'alternatives pas que ça regarde à la
vaccination
il y a des études qui sont rien ne sort
pas il est urgent que le cdc gelé ma
puisse nous présenter des études et
invalides et une proposition qu'a
menteuse alternative au vaccin
concernant le vaccin
astrazeneca il n'est probablement pas
plus dangereux que ce combat
ordinairement échec ce qu'il revienne ne
sont pas beaucoup de problématiques
simplement
celui là puisque sur les autres on ne me
rend ce qui est dommage c'est qu'il y
ait autour des contrats et je suis assez
bien placé pour savoir comment ça c'est
au tour des contrats et autour de
l'attitude de certains la bombe
un attentisme pour pouvoir lancer leur
chaîne de production
cet attentisme étant lié à des fous
donné par l'union européenne alors que
d'autres entreprises comme biot étaient
prêts largement amant en ayant pris le
soin de s'appuyer sur une grande
entreprise qui était files est pour
l'heure c'est beaucoup plus tôt les
chaînes de montage des chaînes de
production
il ne reste pas moins vrai que là c'est
une chance et que dans aucun cas les
mâts à ce jour ni les organismes
nationaux n'ont pas les moyens pour
juger précieux rain man doit la
fiabilité des mc st c'est un vrai souci
mais c'est aussi l'invention à payer
pour voir sortir de cette épidémie alors
est donc exact oui faisant raser les
voir donner un autre visage de lui il ya
beaucoup trop d'éléments autour de ce
laboratoire
il est urgent de passer dans la
transparence en tout cas emmanuel macron
était un valenciennes aujourd'hui et il
annonce une accélération de la campagne
de vaccination c'est une priorité
nationale
on découvre cette voie la priorité
aujourd'hui semble-t-il ce dont doutent
d'ailleurs le leader de la france
insoumise
jean luc mélenchon écoutez si vous
voulez vacciner nuit et jour et le
maximum de monde il faut un maximum de
doses
j'espère que tout le monde comprend ce
raisonnement parce que il doit être
tellement sophistiqués que monsieur
macro n'arrive pas à le comprendre
donc il faut faire venir des vaccins joe
partout voilà une des réponses nous leur
avons dit qu' il fallait demander tous
les vaccins du monde n'est pas s'arrêter
à des préjugés idéologiques ou des
règlements de comptes entre pays
ça va même un peu loin pour certains
députés écoutez la réaction de gilles
lebreton au député européen identité et
démocratie la commission de bruxelles
boycott le vaccin russe il est pourtant
plus fiable que l'astra zeneca dont le
manque de toute façon la hongrie la
tchéquie et la slovaquie l'on commande
est quand même et ont bien fait ludovic
toro vous y croyez justement à cette
notion de boycott des vaccins russe
parce que c'est vrai qu'on se pose la
question à regarder cette carte
y a pas que la hongrie un cacique
monsieur lebreton 56 pays utilisent le
spoutnik vais pourtant il ya une forme
voilà de scepticisme et c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est un euphémisme
quand on entend thierry breton le
commissaire européen à leur boycott
idéologique
thierry breton s'est trompé en
s'exprimant la façon en disant tout
allait bien on n'a pas besoin de vaccins
ce pique nique mais tout autre au vaccin
on a besoin de vaccin de tous les
vaccins mais sauf qu'il passe tout
simplement comme ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs que je vous rappelle
cosmétiques et entrant l'avoir naim aime
ou pas auprès de l'europe
donc ça c'est fait ça va être entérinée
très bientôt oui ou non mais dans tous
les cas là ça va être aussi simple vous
êtes confiant les rôles et les leurs
aujourd'hui il ya quatre pays ont signé
un contrat avec les russes d'accord par
rapport à l'italie et à l'espagne à
l'allemagne ces trois pays vont en effet
vouloir la réponse aux états et même
européenne s'est de facto ça pourra pas
passer autrement on ne peut pas
maintenant peut-être qui sortira avec un
nom mais ils font foi l'étudier point de
vue de là et même a priori les mêmes
française toujours appel et la borne la
m
européennes ont après la ministre
française donc c'est tout il ya même pas
discuter ça soit le spoutnik ou un autre
ce sont des médicaments pour essayer
donc en l'occurrence des vaccins pour
ressortir cette pandémie
donc voilà ce qu'a dit je pense thierry
breton est un peu est totalement exagéré
vont pas dire on n'a pas besoin et
surtout je vous rappelle il a surtout
dit que le 14 juillet se serait terminée
six toiles sera 80% dignité collective
qui est totalement impossible car vous
vous citiez l'allemagne a eu deux vies
qu'un taureau je vous propose d'écouter
justement le député des républicains des
apps maritimes eric ciotti de la merkel
qu'en dit emmanuel macron arrêtons le
blocage politique du vaccin spoutnik v
ce relents de guerre froide alors que
près de cent mille français sont déjà
morts de coronavirus est indigne est
grave et joëlle mélin le fameux
pragmatisme allemand il faut suivre
effectivement l'allemagne désormais
manuel micro on doit arrêter ce qu'eric
ciotti qualifie de blocage politique
écoutez ce que je te répondre malgré
tout on est d'ordinaire l'oma tu es beau
réaliste et le fait
lité du vaccin ce prix unique en france
et en europe n'est pas comme l'a rappelé
aux confrères les procédures sont
simples c'est dur d'autorisation de mise
sur le marché par le roi et par les
polémiques et adopteront ce vaccin bien
comprendre c'est que bien le cas de
figure il capte pour les laboratoires et
les 25es produisions des contrats avec
la commission européenne et qui eux ont
d'emblée à peu près concomitamment
étaient autorisés à l'union européenne
chauffer à ce jour et les autres
médecins sont produits en dehors de ces
cinq à six contrats qui ont été signés
par la commission européenne
nous devons pouvoir faire appel à toutes
les doses des vaccins qui ont
contractualisé avec la commission
européenne
pouvoir avoir accès à la totalité des
autres laboratoires qu'ils soient
chinois qu'ils soient russes qu'il soit
pour d'autres d'amérique du sud certains
et qu'ils puissent dès l'instant qu'ils
sont reconnues comme fiables venir
compléter notre gamme nous pouvons plus
continuer comme ça parce que à force de
variants il est clair que quand on aura
fini cette vaccination là se retrouvent
dans un call qui ressemble à celui là
qui est tentant d'en affiner couvrir
certains mutants peut-être pas d'autres
la fin à la fana maxine à la période de
vaccination
on va se retrouver à devoir vacciner
donc cela est insupportable
il convient donc d'avoir des vaccins les
plus fiables et les plus larges
possibles pour anticiper les mutations
comme on le fait tous les ans avec la
grée des alternatives à la vaccination
pour rassurer tout le monde
cela doit pouvoir se faire tout
particulièrement l'europe a mis sur la
table et font extrêmement important
c'est l'argent des contribuables les
contribuables doivent retrouver leur
argent sous forme de soi en tout cas ces
vaccins et notamment le vaccin à russin
est devenu l'objet de dissensions entre
la russie et l'union européenne je vous
propose d'écouter quand même vadimir
poutine un petit peu courroucé on peut
le comprendre peut-être après les propos
de thierry breton qui soupçonne une
lenteur un petit peu volontaire le
président russe ces nombreux sont ceux
qui ne savent pas ce qu il a réussi à
déposer il y a longtemps de demande
d'enregistrement de son vaccin auprès de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
cela a été fait comme tatiana golikova
me l'a rapporté ce matin le 21 janvier
et ce n'est que le 4 mars que nous avons
été informés du fait que notre demande
commencer à être examinées 1 ludovic
toro il a raison quand même un vladimir
poutine de s'inquiéter de 2,7
lenteur européenne et on va essayer de
sauver la france l'europe et le monde
entier avec la vaccination
il est grand temps d'arrêter de se
battre et de s'affronter soit parce que
le vaccin bien l'angleterre d'amérique
de russie d'accord on n'a pas pu le
faire en français on l'a reconnu pour
différentes raisons les salles après
lisa ultérieurement
aujourd'hui si un vaccin qui peut nous
aider à supporter cette pandémie bien
sûr foule prendre je vous rappeler quand
même une étude sur le lance cette lan
700d journal de référence pour nous car
l'angleterre qui a publié sur le spo
cliquer sur les phases 1 2 et 3 mais
c'est plutôt pour l'instant encourageant
alors il faut attendre sur les mêmes qui
a été déposée ou verra bien ce que lille
europe mais déjà dire de la part de
monsieur breton j'en veux pas je
comprends un peu n'importe quel
président d'un pays auquel ils auraient
au recteur créé ça surtout que l'aï même
est en cours dire qu'ils menaient même
qui est en cours et on dit qu'on n'en
aura pas besoin
et puis je vous rappelle quand même que
sa présidente ursula von dach hier a dit
qu'on aura besoin de tous qu'on s'est
trompé sur les commandes qu'on a été
trop naïf que ceux-ci que cela bon il
faudrait pas que ce commissaire
contredisent quand même sa présidente ça
serait quand même la moindre des choses
d'accord au mois très clairement en tant
que médecin il faut des vaccins d'accord
pour vacciner le plus possible qu'ils
viennent de n'importe où franchement
j'en ai rien à faire pourquoi parce
qu'il ya urgence vraiment à traiter et à
sony le pays est au coeur du coeur du
réacteur puisque vous êtes députée
européenne clément bonin le secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
nous dit le vaccin russe a déposé son
dossier il est examiné tout va bien deux
à trois mois au total on est dans cette
phase
ce ne sera pas avant la fin mai début
juin
c'est normal c'est le rythme européen
on a bien vu que la commission
européenne quand elle a voulu lancer les
travaux a commencé à avoir des corps et
des contacts dès le mois de juillet avec
différents laboratoires
elle aurait parfaitement pu en avoir
aussi avec les laboratoires en
particulier la recherche publique un
petit peu plus en russie avec tous les
intervenants de tous les pays du monde
ils n'ont pas souhaité le faire je pense
que la commission européenne comme
emmanuel macron accumulé énormément
retard au d'erreurs ou de véritable
contresens
il est urgent que tout le monde reprenne
raison et voir la situation comme elle
est nous avons à priori ce qui a l'air
de se dégager ce n'est pas une épidémie
avec des rebonds c'est plusieurs
épidémies avec les virus un peu plus
spécifique de chaque période qui a
expliqué que j'en avais pendant les
périodes chaudes les périodes froides
alors qu'on comprenait pas trop ce qui
se passait l'union européenne doit
impérativement se reprendre
la commission européenne doit se
reprendre et il faut que emmanuel macron
reprenne son indépendance on ne peut pas
vivre uniquement sous la tutelle de les
maquiller d'accord d'accord et qui donne
qui s'était à peine donné 48 heures pour
dire qu'un vaccin était mauvais un jour
me dont le lendemain nous sommes dans
des périodes très compliqué où il va
être éventuellement difficile de trouver
les responsabilités si nous avons face à
nous des aléas médicaux il faut que tout
le monde puisse être assurée il faut que
les états membres reprennent leur
liberté en matière de santé travaillent
ensemble soit en coordination en matière
de santé publique mais reprennent leur
souffle et sanitaires ludovic toro vous
êtes d'accord avec reprenne sa
souveraineté comme à d'ailleurs menacé
de le faire un gala marcal hier en
allemagne
moi je suis vraiment un pro européen
mais d'ailleurs la présidente de la
commission de la dic a eu des erreurs de
gestion d abord de commandes celle-là
reconnu d'accord mais pour l'instant
c'est vrai que moi ce que j'aurais
souhaité c'est que les ministres de la
santé de tous les pays européens sepa
fassent des contrôles puissent et puis
échanger entre eux on dirait que chaque
pays fait ce qu'il veut
chaque pays passe et comment y échapper
applique des restrictions différentes
il ya eu aucune homogénéité de tous les
pays alors maintenant il ya eu les mêmes
qui va être demandé qu'à demander à
l'europe mais pourquoi pas lancer en
même temps une à et même sur la fois sur
le dire puisque toute façon vous avez
mis lui-même européenne et même
française pourquoi attendre l'autorité
européenne alors qu'on a en france
grandement ce qu'il faut pour juger ou
pas de serre médicaments bon on le fait
tous les jours tous les jours sans
l'autorisation de l'europe
on valide des médicaments puisque notre
autonomie décisionnelle
pourquoi les mêmes n'a pas été lancée
aujourd'hui
pour la france sauf si la france décide
de ne pas prendre le spoutnik et voilà
mais je pense que je vous le dis juste
qu'il se passe en allemagne aujourd'hui
6 à synnex s'accélère pas ils vont faire
une et même que moralement il y aura là
mêmes qui sera en espagne et mauritanie
et là encore ça qu'on fera pas comment
dire l'efficacité de notre europe dans
cette gestion entre cette pandémie
merci en tout cas à tous les deux les
devis 4 euros joëlle mélin d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france ce soir
merci à vous deux